إنه يكفي لتدفئة
جميع رؤساء أمريكا الذين يتلقون
معاملة بيلي راي سايروس التي تعامل
مثل جو ديرت من LBJ إلى JFK، هؤلاء
الرؤساء يبدون مخدرين في مذيع
البودكاست والكاميرا الكوميدية، من
الأفضل أن يفكر هارلس في ذلك، لذا فقد ابتكرها مستوحاة
من فيلم Roadhouse، فقط محظوظ على ما
أعتقد.  استخدمت الكاميرا
مولدًا فنيًا للذكاء الاصطناعي يسمى
منتصف الرحلة، استغرق الأمر ثلاث ساعات فقط، وكان هناك
جو بايدن يبدو وكأنه
كلب جديد ومحسن، وخرج صياد الجوائز وآبي
يبدو وكأنه فاتنة من تيدي
روزفلت إلى بيل كلينتون، قد تكون الولايات المتحدة
منقسمة بشكل ميؤوس منه ولكن  كل ما يتطلبه الأمر هو
عدد قليل من البوري وبضعة أزواج من النظارات الشمسية،
ونحن أكثر اتحادًا مما كنا عليه من قبل
بعض الرؤساء مثل ريتشارد نيكسون الذي
اختبر ذكاء
الذكاء الاصطناعي كما فعل دوايت أيزنهاور في
محاولة الذكاء الاصطناعي لإعطاء هذا الرجل الأصلع
البوري  كان أمرًا جديرًا بالثناء، لقد انتهى الأمر بآيك مع
الموهوك وليس البوري بقدر ما هو
القرمزي، وأعتقد أنه قبل 20 عامًا
بدلاً من الذكاء الاصطناعي
كان علينا اللجوء إلى الشعر المستعار لنرى كيف
سنبدو في البوري
الجميل الآن هيا إلى الذكاء الاصطناعي  واجهت مشكلة
مع وودرو ويلسون وجورج
واشنطن، وقد حثني أحد المعجبين على وضع ذلك على
فاتورة الدولار
مقابل 16 دولارًا، حيث يمكنك الحصول على ملصق لجميع
الرؤساء البوريين، إصدار الجحيم نعم،
يطلق عليه مدرس طلب
واحدًا لفصل الدراسات الاجتماعية وكنت
مثل  نعم، كطفل ولد في الثمانينات،
اختبر البوري مباشرة، فقد
نما عليه حرفيًا تحية للبوري،
ارفع رأسك إلى هذا
[موسيقى]
سي إن إن
نيويورك